kill bill star michael madsen has been
arrested just one month after his son's
suspected suicide made headlines
according to multiple reports the
64-year old actor was arrested wednesday
night in malibu on suspicion of
misdemeanor trespassing the la sheriff's
department deputies were called to
madsen's malibu home which he was
renting at around 9pm wednesday night by
the property's owner who detained the
actor in a citizen's arrest according to
lasd arrest records obtained by e.t
madsen was then transported to west
hills hospital before being taken to the
sheriff's lost hill station where he was
issued a 500 citation and released
thursday morning it's unclear at this
time why the owner of the property
madsen had been renting called the
police on the actor but his arrest comes
just one month after the death of his 26
year old son hudson who died of a
gunshot wound to the head on a suspected
suicide on the hawaiian island of oahu
shortly after his son's tragic passing
the reservoir dog star shared the final
text message he received from his son
with the los angeles times a text
reading simply i love you dad
quote i am in shock as my son whom i
just spoke with a few days ago said he
was happy hudson the god son of quentin
tarantino was madsen's eldest son with
his wife deanna madsen the two also
share sons calvin and luke madsen also
shares sons christian and max with his
ex-wife janine bissignano following
hudson's death the family released a
statement to metro stating that they are
heartbroken and overwhelmed by grief and
pain adding his memory and light will be
remembered by all who knew and loved him
[Music]
you